we're now going to look at solving
linear equations systems of linear
equations
so we'll start with something called
back substitution
the name will become clear uh shortly so
here's the idea
we have a matrix r it's upper triangular
with non-zero diagonal entries now that
means that r
is invertible we've already discussed
that um and so
we're going to write out the equation rx
equals b and of course what we're
actually calculating here if we're going
to solve for x is we have x
equals r inverse b i can write this
because r
is invertible because it's upper
triangular with
with non-zero diagonal entries okay so
i'm going to write
write this out in scalars and this is
basically r is upper triangular so it
looks like this it's r 1 1 x 1 plus r 1
2 x 2 and so on
that's the first equation and the first
equation notice involves
all the variables x1 x2 x3 all the way
up to xn
the second equation by the way involves
only the variables
x2 x3 x4 up to xn that's because it's
upper triangular
and the last equation that's right down
here pretty simple
it simply only involves xn right the
penultimate equation only involves xn
minus 1 and xn
now let's what we want to do we want to
calculate x we want to basically solve
for x
so let's start from the last equation
from the last equation you see rnn
xn equals bn now these are just numbers
right
oh and not only that and this is
critical we know that rnn
is not zero and so that tells us
immediately that we just divide
and we get xn equals bn over rnn
now we know xn okay now
from the second to last equation let's
focus on that one
it says r n minus 1n minus 1xn minus 1
plus rn minus 1
n x n equals n but you know what we know
x n
so what we're going to do is we're going
to take this equation
and we're going to write x n is the
right hand side the n minus 1
minus this part now we already know that
part this thing
because we just calculated xn divided by
rn minus 1 rn minus 1. and again we can
do that because rn minus 1
comma n minus 1 is a diagonal entry of r
and it's assumed to be non-zero
so i get xn and then basically we just
continue this
we now we know after this step we know x
n and we know x n minus one
now we get x n minus two then x n minus
three and eventually we end up with x
one
okay so uh it's called back substitution
for the obvious reason
um is we're going backwards we're first
calculating x n and then
substituting in known values into the uh
the formulas and then
uh just analytically working out what uh
what the various x's are in backward
order
okay um so this is the idea and it's
going to compute
x equals r inverse b so we now have a
perfectly good way to do that let's talk
about the complexity like how long does
this take
well the first step is uh well you have
to divide it's you know it's whatever it
is it's bn
divided by rnn that's one flop one
division
um the second step and the second step
is over here let's see what we got to do
we've got to multiply uh these two
numbers we've got to do a subtraction
and then maybe a division so maybe
that's three flops
uh here okay so the second step needs
three flops
and the the i step you know the third
step needs five flops then
seven and so on and so the total is
going to be 1 plus 3
plus 5 plus 7 all the way up to 2 n
minus 1.
and it's a it's a famous identity
uh that tells you that the sum of the
first two n minus
whatever the first the sum of odd
numbers up to 2n minus 1
is just n squared uh so and you can
check that it's easy enough but we may
even
uh explain how you figure that out in
the book or something like that anyway
um it's it's actually not not too hard
to show um
so it's going to cost you n squared
flops uh to actually do
back substitution um by the way that's
the same order as matrix vector multiply
uh right so if you multiply a matrix and
by n matrix by vector
it's around n squared maybe it's 2 n
squared plots something like that so
back substitution is in the same order
as that
okay now turns out now we can solve
linear equations
via qr factorization um so
let's start with a matrix a that's
invertible so it's square
and we're going to solve ax equals b
which means to compute x equals a
inverse b
um so we start with the qr factorization
of a
a has independent columns because it's
invertible so the qr factorization
completes and we write it as a equals qr
q is square it's an orthogonal matrix
meaning
it's square and its columns are
orthonormal now by the way so it's rows
and then r r is an upper triangular
matrix with
positive diagonal entries and therefore
it's invertible
so a is a product of two invertible
matrices and so the inverse
first of all number one we conclude a is
invertible number one
number two it's inverse is the product
is the a product of the inverses
of the multiplicands uh in reverse order
so
uh a inverse is going to be qr inverse
and that's going to be r
inverse times q inverse but q in versus
q transpose
so um so that's it so what we do then
is now we know how to do it because what
we can do
is we're going to compute this we're
going to compute x by back substitution
first we're going to multiply by q
transpose b
we know how to do matrix vector
multiplication and then to compute
x equals r inverse q transpose b we use
back substitution
right so that's kind of the idea so
here's the algorithm written out as some
pseudo code it works like this um
a pseudocode it works like this we're
going to we're given an n by an
invertible matrix a and an n vector b
the first thing is to do qr
factorization um that costs us
well we'll get to that that's 2n cubed
flops roughly
then we calculate q transpose b that's a
matrix vector multiply
and then finally we call back
substitution on on this system of
equations we can do that because
r is upper triangular with non-zero
diagonal elements and that's using back
substitution so
step one here costs two n cubed
flops step two that's a matrix vector
multiply that's two n
squared and the last one back
substitution is
n squared and so the total what you see
immediately
is when you add these up steps 2
and 3 cost very little in fact they're
negligible
because we're imagining n to be large i
mean we're not thinking n 10. we're
thinking a hundred thousand ten thousand
and what it turns out is that steps two
and three are actually negligible
because
they're proportional their order is n
squared and the first step is just this
qr factorization
so what it means is that the real cost
of solving linear equations is just qr
factorization
which can be calculated by the
gram-schmidt algorithm
okay so by the way this at this point
the gram-schmidt algorithm should be
looking
a lot more interesting earlier in the
course
gram-schmidt algorithm was nothing but a
numerical algorithm that tells you
whether a set of vectors is linearly
independent
now what we see is it can be used to
solve
equations linear systems of linear
equations and that's great because
that's already a whole lot of
applications can be done
uh this way so the total complexity
altogether
is the second and third are completely
negligible that when you're doing a flop
count you would ignore
something proportional n squared
compared to n cubed so it's basically 2n
cubed
is is what the cost of solving
a x equals b is for a and n by n matrix
and i'll give you some rough uh ideas
about this let's uh
let's let's do this let's solve
a x equals b with a
a one thousand by one thousand matrix
okay so
um first of all that is a they would
appear to be at least for to a person
that looks like a pretty big set of
linear equations it's
we have a thousand variables x1 x2 x3 up
to x1000 number one
and we have a thousand equations in them
right so all together
the matrix a which are the coefficients
in my system of linear equations
has a million numbers in it i mean i
could make it sound like
super you know complicated and big um
i can solve this in one tenth of a
second on my laptop
which is five years old okay so
that is just absolutely stunning
right it it's in fact that's kind of
very interesting part about this class
right is
that is that we we do these things but
they're actually like fully actionable
and you can solve a whole lot bigger and
it's a lot faster on other types of
hardware like on a gpu
or something like that it's very very
fast but
these are just stunning speeds uh that
so we can solve giant sets of equations
uh this way
okay um the next thing we're going to
talk about is actually solving
multiple sets of linear equations and
it's going to come back to this idea
that of the three steps required to
solve ax equals b
it's only the qr factorization of the
coefficient matrix that actually
costs anything the others i mean they
cost something in terms of flops but
they're negligible compared to the first
step
so what that means is this it's a
situation where we're going to solve
axi equals bi i equals
1 to k so i'm going to call i'm going to
solve k systems of linear equations
with a invertible and so the right hand
sides are different
i have b1 b2 b3 up to bk
and of course the solutions are
different that's x1 and x2 x3
um but the coefficient matrix a is the
same for all of them and so what we do
is we're going to be smart and we're
going to carry out the qr factorization
just
once okay and then the only thing we're
going to repeat
is we're going to repeat for each that
right-hand side
we're going to actually do the back
substitution and multiplication by q
transpose right
that that's n squared uh flops um and so
the total is two n cubed plus three k
n squared flops and what you see is
pretty
stunning that as long as k is like small
it's it basically is still completely
negligible
and this is just completely weird and
insane this is one of the first things
that that
you know is kind of shocking so
basically what it says
is well let's take my laptop suppose i
ask you to solve
a x i equals
bi for i equals 1
up to 10. okay so i want to go to i want
to do 10. i want to solve 10
systems of linear equations and a is a
thousand by thousand
now we already discussed that we found
out that i can solve this in about a
tenth of a second on my laptop
fine oh sorry i can solve one of them in
a tenth of a second
okay so the naive method would be just
simply
solve this ten times and that would give
me ten times a tenth of a second which
is one
second okay um but in fact
what this says is if i'm smart i only
have to the only one i
i i do let's go back here i do step one
once
and then it's step two and three that i
repeat ten times
but the point is that the it's the what
people would say is that the first step
dominates meaning it's much it takes
much more time to carry out the first
step
and so what we conclude here is that i
can solve
uh you know someone walks up to you and
says help me solve one set of linear
equations thousand by thousand i go no
problem
tenth of a second and they go cool i'd
like to solve now 10
10 systems of linear equations same
coefficient matrix how long is that
going to take and you would normally
think well
a second and the actual answer is
0.1 seconds it's the same so in others
you can make the crazy statement
as a practical matter i can solve ten
systems of linear equations
thousand by thousand and basically the
same time it takes me to solve one
okay so that is weird i mean unexpected
but you know
once you know all the parts it all it
all makes perfect sense
okay what we're going to do now is look
at just a couple of very simple examples
uh there are many many many others
but let's take a look at them the first
one is in polynomial interpolation
so what we'll do is we're going to
represent a polynomial that's p of x
it's a polynomial of one variable scalar
variable x and i'm going to write it as
c one
plus c two x plus c two c three x
squared plus c four
x cubed okay so it's a it's a quartic no
it's a cubic sorry it's a cubic
polynomial
it has four coefficients four because it
also has the constant coefficient so c
one is the x to the zero coefficient c2
is the x to the one coefficient
and so on okay and what i'll do is i'm
going to represent
um the coefficient of the polynomial its
coefficients as a 4 vector
c okay so when you see a 4 vector now
it's going to represent a polynomial
okay and what i want to do is i want to
find
a cubic polynomial that satisfies these
conditions
um so when you evaluate it at minus 1.1
you should get v1
when you evaluate it minus 0.4 you
should get b2 at point 1 you should get
b3
and at point a you should get b4 and b1
through b4 are numbers that i have not
yet specified
okay so oh by the way this is called
polynomial interpolation because what it
means is
you want the plot of the polynomial the
curve
of the polynomial when you draw it it
should go through specific points so it
should go through the point
minus 1.1 comma b okay so that's called
interpolation when you go through
these interpolation points okay now
we can write these interpolation
conditions
as uh well just a set of linear
equations it's ac
equals b okay and to check that
you would put c1 uh you know c2
c3 and c4 here right and
and see if this is what it's supposed to
be
um okay and then that's not a equals so
just get rid of that there we go
okay so let's see if this faithfully
gives you these interpolation conditions
well if you look at if you go across
this first row
and with these coefficients what you
will find is that you are eval
this first row of the product is
actually evaluating p
at the point minus 1.1 ah but that
should be v1 and sure enough that's the
right hand side
so so this is correct so these these
polynomial interpolation conditions
uh basically are i write as a set of
four by four
uh linear equations a system of linear
equations
um yeah by the way this would be exactly
even though this is like it's from a
computer's point of view this is
pathetically small
this is already way bigger than what any
human being should do like so
well it's too late now but if you had
classes before where people
you know tortured you by solving like
three by three sets of linear systems
that was really in my opinion a complete
waste of time and four by four would be
off scale so
could you do this by hand using some
kind of high school method you know
whatever it is gaussian elimination
oh you could but it wouldn't be fun and
it's a complete waste of time i should
add that also
okay so this if we solve this set of
equations
we will get the coefficients um okay and
in fact we can even say this
c is equal to a inverse b
i should say a couple of things this
matrix has a name
a matrix whose rows consist of a number
to the zero number to the one
two three up to certain powers it's
called a vandermonde matrix named after
a mathematician named van der mondt
and it is invertible um and it's
invertible because
these numbers were all different right
so that's that's actually the condition
i haven't shown that
uh but that's the case that's the idea
okay so
i get this is just a compact formula
that tells me these are the
you know you tell me what you want where
you want your polynomial to go through
at these four points
and i'll tell you what the coefficients
are so that's how that works
okay um so here uh a inverse uh this is
to four significant figures i mean
obviously there it's more more than this
but here it is a inverse is this matrix
here
um and you look at it and you think wow
okay whatever
uh so if you multiply this matrix by
this matrix here uh you will get
something
close to the identity actually because
i've only given the other ones to four
significant figures you
you'd get numbers on the diagonals like
0.99999
and and the off diagonal entries would
be super small right
okay so here's a inverse and
let's see what it is what's the
interpretation of a inverse well
a inverse and entries of a inverse
map b these are the the values that
you're
that you're uh that your polynomial
should take at these four points
into the coefficients and so for example
we would notice that um
that these are these are like the
smallest entries in the whole
matrix and what it says is let's
interpret that
so over here i would put b and then this
would give me the c
this would give me c and so what this
means is
i can say that the first coefficient is
not very sensitive to what b1 or b4 is
okay well who knew but it's true that's
what this says
another interesting thing is to is to
actually interpret the columns right
columns are super interesting like let's
figure out what the first column
means so here's the first column what
does it mean well
that column is if i multiply a inverse
by e1
i get the first column that's true for
any matrix
ah but wait a minute e1 are the values
that that polynomial should take and
that says that the first the first
column gives you the coefficients
of a polynomial that satisfies this at
minus one point one it's one
and minus point four is zero zero zero
this is like e one
the right hand side okay now that's got
a name
a polynomial that is equal to one at a
specified value and
zero at at other values that's called
the lagrange polynomial
and it's literally the coefficients of
the uh of the
it's the coefficients of the that appear
in the column of the inverse of this van
der waan matrix
okay and here's an example um and
what we're showing you here is a couple
of these so first of all this is us
um solving this for a couple of uh for a
couple of different cases this is minus
1.1
and so for example if you specify these
values
um you know this one this one this one
and this one
you'll get the polynomial it'll go right
through
it'll go right through those points
because we've constructed it that way
so that's the idea here are the lagrange
polynomials
so here's the first lagrange polynomial
associated with these points here um
and let's see how that works well uh
what it says
is that you have one uh and
you have one and zero and so this first
polynomial looks like that it's a cubic
and sure enough look at that at minus
one point one it's one
at minus point four at zero it's again
zero at point two and also at point
eight
here's the second lagrange polynomial
lagrange polynomial associated with
these points
is this uh it's zero at minus one point
one
at minus point eight it it minus point
four i'm sorry it's one
uh it is point zero again zero at point
two and also at point eight
so these are the lagrange polynomials
okay so
and these are each one has coefficients
associated with the columns of the
inverse of a